- ♫ We're Jewish, it's Christmas
♫ There's no Yuletide cheer
♫ So bugger the eggnog
♫ And (grunts) the reindeer ♫
- That is not a Jewish thing.
- (laughs)
Jews Decorate Christmas Trees
- I've never touched a Christmas tree.
I assume if I did, my hands
would burn or something.
- It's just about glitter.
- I think Christmas sucks.
- I feel like I'll be pretty good at this.
- Christmas sweater!
- Let's see what we have here.
- Why do they make Jesus a baby?
- Anything with a hook on
it, let's put on the tree.
- That was pretty good!
Look at that, I just threw on--
- No!
- Oh wait, we could put eyes under it too.
- Ok.
Oh, that's not so hard.
- She has a nice little angel yarmulke.
- Put my keys on there.
- She needs a belt.
- This tree looks delicious.
- Smells great.
- (crunches teeth)
- This tree looks super fake.
- This is tacky.
- Just because we're Jewish, we know
what real trees are supposed to look like.
- I guess candy canes are
good at hanging on trees,
because they're definitely terrible candy.
- I feel like if my family did this,
we would just leave the tree up forever,
because no one would want to clean it up.
- Look at this skirt, it's
not even covering her knees.
- Are pinecones, is that Christian?
- Is this the Virgin Mary?
- I don't know if the
Virgin Mary had wings.
- My understanding is the
goys sing while they do this?
- ♫ All I want for Christmas ♫
- Oh could you name those seven reindeer?
Galant!
- Knoll.
- Like a grassy knoll.
- Who is Noel?
Is Noel God, is he Jesus?
- Dancer...
- Dancer.
- Lemony.
- Nope.
- Can I just wrap parts
of it in aluminum foil?
- It's conspiracy theory tree.
- They rhyme, a lot of them rhyme!
Lancer, Prancer, Gandalf...
- Yeah, you can put that on.
If you want to go to Hell.
- One, two, three!
Yay!
- Merry Christmas!
Those are definitely a fire hazard.
- I feel like if a rabbi sees this,
they're gonna kick me out of Judaism.
- I'm not a Jew anymore, right?
- I think I killed it.
- I don't know why everyone's
always making a big deal
about decorating a Christmas tree.
I feel like we did it pretty
quickly and totally kicked ass.
Happy Holidays!
- [Voiceover] How do you feel now
that you've decorated a Christmas tree?
- Like a whole new person.
- I'd give it like a B.
- We forgot one thing.
Mistletoe.
- Yeah, I'm reasonably
sure we got everything.